hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna add a demo mode to our app and
I'll explain why right now so if you
haven't been with us for the last six
live streams we've been building an app
a brain-computer app that works with a
brain-computer interface to grab your
brainwaves measure them to see how
focused you are and then warn you if
your focus is dropping below a certain
level we successfully submitted that app
to the Google Play Store and then we
submitted it to the Apple App Store and
it took a while to get any feedback back
but you could see on the screen now
I did get some feedback for that app so
I just got that feedback probably at
some point in the past week so basically
since I just created my account as an
apple developer it took a few weeks for
them to approve my account after they
improved my account it really only took
him a day to review the app and what
they said was they can't test all the
functionality of the app because they
don't have an account to login with now
they also don't have the device so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna create a
demo account so this is exactly what
they suggested it says please be sure
just please provide a username and
password in the App Store review so
we're going to provide a username and
password please be sure that the demo
account includes content that
demonstrates the features and
functionality available in your app and
so we're going to do a check now
whenever somebody logs in if they log in
with certain information we're gonna
bypass everything that the app does and
we're just going to kind of show like
random data basically we're gonna kind
of mock the data that would normally
come in without having to have the brain
computer interface or it connected to
any type of API just so that whoever's
testing this for Apple when they log in
with the info we give them it shows them
what the app would look like if they
actually did have a notion
brain-computer connected to the device
so that's the plan we'll see how long it
takes I think we can get it done and
resubmitted and in about an hour I'm
hoping we'll see how it goes I'm gonna
answer some questions so if you have
questions put them in the live chat I'll
I'm gonna set a timer and we're going to
spend about 25 minutes on the code and
then we will do about five minutes of
question-and-answer and then we'll do
another code session and then TN will do
some more question and answer I also
want to release this as a web app maybe
on github pages or something like that I
don't think we'll have time for that on
this stream so if we don't get to it
this stream it'll probably be the next
stream but that's also in in the plans
to happen and there's a few other
features that I'd like to add at some
point but first thing is just get it
released to basically the three
platforms web Apple and Android so my
timer is set and let's get to the code
we can see the app here I'm gonna shrink
this up since we really don't need much
in terms of UI space here and so we
could focus on the code let me know if
the code is too small
is it too okay
he did say the coast useful I'm gonna
bring it out a little bit if I get much
bigger than this I'm not gonna have any
room to actually code so let's look at
where we're kind of like the first step
in logging in and if the user let's see
what gets called oops or submit button
here cause the init function so let's
check out our init function there we go
so this is where I want to check to see
what the the ID email and password are
so let's say this if device ID and we're
gonna say equals test I'm not even gonna
worry about user name and password and
all that stuff now let's just say if the
Vice ID equals test then we will it's
just in it demo so we're gonna have to
create in it demo
alright so an it demo is gonna be as I
said a bypass of all of our
authentication and connecting up to an
API so this will be
this is gonna be interesting how we're
gonna get this let's check our state cuz
that's where everything goes through so
we have our focus the main thing we need
to do is focus and I gotta remember what
takes us to the next screen so our focus
is gonna set let's just let's let's try
that first
let's check the screen first because I
want something visible to show right
away like what's going on with the
screen so okay it looks like user so if
user exists and that's what we do so
what we'll do is we'll just set user I
don't think I have tight script on how
many types yet on anything which is
actually gonna be good for now even
though this is a tsx file for type
scripts I didn't add types to anything
yet so I don't have to worry about that
for now so a knit demo is going to set
user to true setting user to true should
take us to the next screen now hopefully
it won't cause a bunch of errors and
issues because that's definitely like
users not supposed to be a boolean right
but let's just see what happens for now
set usually true and then we're gonna do
set focus well let's do this let's do a
timeout that's how you want to do it
I wonder if we should do
alright here's what I'm thinking I like
to just like replay all the like a data
that we would be getting in like over
and over again but
I'm not sure the best way to do that
maybe I mean we could do like set
timeouts let's see if there's something
like that
let's see JavaScript JavaScript timing
events that's kind of what I want
let's go mdn I like that better
look I want to see the related set
interval this might be what I want more
okay the set interval method offered on
the window repeatedly calls the function
or execute code that's what we want with
a fixed time delay between each call
all right cool that's what we want set
interval so let's grab the example code
and then just adapt it to what we have
here so interesting
I don't think we need all those
parameters uh did this problem okay
look there interesting
I I don't think we need anything extra
we can just pop this in here so let's
try this and we'll go with a set
interval and inside our set interval
we'll do see if we can do this with like
an arrow function and our second
parameter for a set interval our first
foraminal parameter is going to be this
function right this arrow function which
we'll do in a second but our timing is
going to be let's give it a timing of
like one second right so at this
milliseconds thousand milliseconds is
one second now inside of here what I
want to do is I want to set focus now
focus is going to be a number between
zero and one so I want to set the focus
to to do like a random number I don't
exactly remember that syntax Brendan
love it there we go
math there we go math dot random she got
an M I believe this will automatically
be between zero and one yep cool that's
exactly what we want
math dot random cool
so then that should mean that at the set
interval it'll be every one second it
will set a different random number for
our focus and that is going to imitate
data coming in from the API setting our
focus so let's try this out I have this
running in a web right now so let's do
test and submit sweet it works
cool awesome all right that's pretty
cool that way it's just to make sure I
can log out and good it's not blinking I
want to make sure that that interval is
is actually not still running so I want
to inspect this and see where react and
his States
you probably can't see any of this let
me make it bigger whoa
just a little bigger ah there we go oh
you know what that still is going to we
need a way to stop our interval let's
check this again how do we stop the
interval clearinterval set interval and
set times your simple idea isn't clear
in a world clear time activity whoops
all right let's see if I can just run
clearinterval to stop this
nope that does not work I might have to
actually name this see how they need
Monsieur the return interval ID okay is
a nonzero value which identifies the
timer created interesting so there is a
return value from set interval so we
should be able to set the interval ID by
this one if you could do actually
we're gonna make another part of the
state here right and this will be
gonna set interval ID to null at first
and then what we'll do is in our log out
let's see you know logout function we're
gonna go set into old ID oops
send interval ID and we're gonna add
hopes I'm sorry that's not what I meant
I'm going to say clear interval and
we're gonna say interval ID so that
should clear the interval for us
hopefully see if that works just pull
that out so first let's verify that okay
so we don't we don't have the let's make
sure in the right one there we go
alright so nothing's changing in our in
our state here and you see the values
are staying the same let's submit you
can see now we do have our state
changing
let's hit logout and now that we've
logged out it has stopped so our
interval is stopped all right our focus
is thought not only that but you know
what let's let's clear our focus so once
we clear the interval let's set focus to
what's our default for focus let's check
this is zero so guess let's just set it
back down to zero just to reset
everything to how it normally is
alright let's test that one more time
test log out wonderful oh no not so
wonderful right because what it's it
took us back down to zero
alright we don't want that and we shut
the user the user is set back to null
why are we still back down to let's see
see where our colors coming from
background color okay where are we
setting our background color when our
focus changes that's what's happening
but really it should be a focus or user
changes correct and then we're gonna say
let's try that let's see if that fixes
our issue issue being that that turned
red now you know to kept it red I don't
like that
let's make sure so we should still why
is that so red well we could what we
could do I think I'm still gonna keep
that because that makes sense
but we could also do is on logout we
could set background set background
color to white
so FFF would be white let's see if that
does what we want great that works okay
alright that solves our problem so now
when we log out it takes us back to
basically the the state we're actually
getting a lot of state here so at some
point I might refactor this so we don't
have a ton of you states perhaps maybe
change that up to a user deucer I don't
really mind that you
a state like this but I don't know when
it starts getting a little bit bigger
then I start to think maybe it's maybe
we need some sort of different system to
manage all the state but right now it's
not too bad all right
I definitely want to do a test of the
actual functionality just to make sure
that this works still so I'm gonna grab
my device ID let's see looks like I
might have this saved now I don't know
close 1 2 3 4 now that's not the right
one yeah I don't think that's variable
okay let me grab my real device ID and
the password actually I'll need to turn
my device on so to make sure now what
we've done shouldn't mess up anything
else for how the app really works but
just in case I want to want to test it
again about about 6 minutes left on the
timer before I'm gonna take a break and
go to the chat so if I if you've asked
the question in chat hang in there for a
couple more minutes and and I'll get to
it here's my device ID whoa interesting
interesting
shut that again
why are we getting that I wonder
that's no good
I wonder it's just ass huh that's really
weird
I wonder what I was actually trying to
paste in there
maybe I maybe I just didn't know realize
what I had paste it in there it was
pasting some in but that's actually not
not bad to do essentially depending on
what you type in there that could really
mess up the the app it could crash the
app so often worked out as a bug this is
nice
sure we can add cool so it looks like
that works I don't really have the
device on it's just kind of sending this
is the device it's just sending like
random signals at this point but we know
it works let's log out awesome cool
everything looks like it works now right
before the stream started I did go into
the app JSON and I said that this is
bill number one point zero point one and
version code for Android I guess we'll
stick with the same can I do that for
Android expected maybe at once
wonderful Oh let me do that fender we're
not gonna build the Android right now
but I'd like to keep these the same if I
can I know before Android didn't like
that I tried to submit an update to the
app with the same version code so that's
why I'm incrementing that I don't know
if iOS is like that but rather rather do
not mess with it and mess it up you know
okay version 1.0 point one will just
increment that cool no let's get status
see what change that looks about right
get ad get commits and put a message in
there and we'll say you added a feature
and it's gonna be add demo mode awesome
now let's push it good push origin
actually I'm on the master branch I can
just get push cool normally it's it's a
pretty good good idea to do any updates
on separate branches and then do a pull
request but since this is a solo project
I'm the only one working on it I'm just
pushing the master if this was a real
project then I probably wouldn't be
doing it like that like it when I'm at
work you don't ever push directly to
master so it's always on a separate
branch all right so that's in now and
let's actually let's go to github
I want to add an issue I believe the
issue is okay I think that was the issue
that the app was crashing I just want to
add it just so I don't forget that's not
like the best reproduction steps like
ideally I would have said exactly what
to type in there so you know if I we
have time later on we can try to
reproduce it and maybe fix that or add
it in but anyway I don't want to forget
it so we added it in now let's go to app
the App Store and oops you know what I
need to do we need to actually make a
build right let's check on Expo let's
see if there's a way for me to update
this app so let's see how we can do
these updates because I might not have
to actually manually move the file let's
see actually my timer just went off so
I'm gonna take a five-minute break and
answer some questions and when we come
back then we're going to upload the
update
where you figure out what the best way
is to update it and then we're actually
gonna update what's in the the App Store
currently so I'm sitting a five-minute
timer and let's go over here and read
some of these comments I'm just going up
to the top and going an order here she
is you brian says is type script
included in this project yes yes it is
I'm not using it throughout everything
yet but it's there mainly I'm not using
it just because trying to kind of go as
fast as I can for a live stream and
especially when when a lot of the code
that I was using it was kind of a
testing and not even sure if it was
working I kind of didn't bother to put
sites in now that things are actually
working though might not be a bad idea
to start adding in types as we go
someone asks if this was Ruby it is not
Ruby it's JavaScript specifically it is
react native which is a JavaScript
library sue Suleiman says what is the
font-family you're using on das code I'm
not even sure what font family amusing
see if I could check the Preferences she
must settings here text editor font size
my font family is console us Co n s Ola
s I was not aware of that must be the
default that comes with it
YouTube's Greece says programmer or
technician the temperatures I don't
really know the difference what do you
mean what do you mean by programmer and
technician it maybe I'll be able to
answer that better
farhad asks if the previous parts are on
free code camp yes they are so just
check out all the brain-computer its
build a brain-computer app with react
native this is part 7 all the other
parts are there except for part 2 part 2
I accidentally deleted so I'm gonna redo
part 2 at some point so that that will
be there I do plan on redoing that but
for now part 2 is not available and
Antica says why react native well I use
react native at my job so it just it's
very easy for me to build with react
native react native allows me to build
for iOS Android and web we're all with
the same codebase
so it's definitely a good choice if
you're working on a project by yourself
like I am with this project because
otherwise you would need such a broad
array of knowledge a knowledge of like
let's say if I were to build for all
those platforms natively on those
platforms oh it would be too much to
remember there's no way I could be an
expert at anyone right but react native
helps you to build to become proficient
in building for all three so anyway
that's why I decided to use it
GUI says I am new at developing and I
want to know can i connect javascript
with a database like my sequel yeah you
definitely can you probably want to use
an API you could like potentially you
could use nodejs to run on a server and
connect with my sequel i it's i guess
it's possible to connect from the front
end to my sequel although I've never
done it or seen it but you know normally
you would if we're talking front-end
JavaScript running like in a browser
normally you would want to expose some
sort of API the API layer would connect
to the database and then so nothing but
the API would directly connect to the
database
okay
just I'm scrolling down looking for more
questions
last question before I go back to the
code says sir Sir Khan says by the way
how is your quarantine actually you know
what the last week was was really good
to be honest with you I it it's been a
little bit rough like my family is doing
all right all my kids are home from
school my wife lost her job but we're
doing alright I I was kind of like
depressed for a couple weeks into this
but the last week I've been feeling
pretty good and the whole family was
doing you know I'm pretty good so you
know right now I think we're just kind
of getting used to it at this point but
anyway how's everything going for you
let me know in the chat or in the
comments like house quarantine going for
you all I know it's probably different
in different areas of the world I'm in
the United States in in Ohio every state
in the United States seems to have
different rules right now in terms of
like what businesses can stay open and
where you're allowed to go so for me
it's pretty much everything is shut down
like hospitals are still open
restaurants are allowed to stay open but
no one can go in them so you you can
just they get food delivered grocery
stores are allowed to stay open but like
all the schools are closed most other
types of businesses are closed so that's
where it's at right now for me I'm I'm
still working even though like my
company basically shut down almost all
their stores
I'm thankfully still still have a job so
that's good so I think I'm doing you
know better a lot of people don't have
jobs anymore but for me I'm you know
thankful to be able to keep keep working
and you know keep supporting my family
but hopefully everything's going all
right for you all to me let me go back
now I know I didn't get to all the
questions I'll get back to them though
but I want to make sure we get this you
know submitted and so far everything's
been going pretty smoothly which is kind
of crazy usually like something there's
some issues so I'm expecting the issues
will happen here in the second part of
the stream here but let's read this just
really quick to see if we want to use
this way to update let's see so these
are over there updates allow you to
publish a new version of your app
without building a new version your
standalone app and resubmit resubmitting
that's awesome that's definitely what
what I want to perform an over-the-air
update of your app you simply run Expo
publish all right I don't think we ever
leased channels so we don't have to do
that
and we didn't change the SDK version so
we don't need to build the update
setting and app dot JSON alright let's
let's check out the update setting in
app dot JSON do because we might need to
set it to true alright let's let's check
out our update setting because I don't I
don't remember if we have this set or
not updates so we have a fallback to we
have that timeout one if it's set to
false
chin up whatever download any code only
use kill device in that case I'll teach
yesterday after it defaults to true ok
so it it should be enabled well let's
try it let's run what do they say
let's run Expo publish and then we can
check to see if it if it worked
cool hey this might end up being yeah
pretty easy so we'll go back here to our
code and let's pull up our terminal
which I did I just closed can i grab it
from here nice it's still there ok cool
so let's run Expo publish
oops validating feels an up Jason okay
we changed that Android version it has
to be an integer all right cool
so I wasn't sure about that let's change
this back whoops this one needs to be an
integer so it was an integer we changed
it to a string so let's just say version
2 then and we'll save that alright just
did a little committed to changes and
get just so I didn't forget sometimes
especially when I'm streaming I'll
forget to update my changes so wanna
make sure I do that alright now let's do
our Expo publish again and see if it
works and we should know if it worked in
the app store because we'll see a new
version number so so far looks like it's
building building an iOS bundle that's
awesome
you know while it's doing its thing
let's go into our App Store and let's
add in you use your access maybe that's
it won't cancel no we want we gotta
change and be able to go back in here
because it says where to go to do this
rejected actually I think it is on this
page bill app review signing required
that's not what I want I want additional
information notes okay alright so this
will give hopefully they don't require
me to enter in these fields because
they're gonna be blank but now at least
they should yeah so let me say demo mode
does not require the use of the Nicene
ition brain-computer okay
all right cool version actually I'm
gonna copy and paste this because I
wonder if if this will change we have to
change the app version let's let's check
on the progress here of our our update
all right cool
so it says publishing of the fall
building iOS she's good
open this up
oops I'd cut off the URL oh well let's
good app store now and see activity
hmm I'm here to Expo go to my XO
dashboard and see what's going on there
overview builds
I wonder what happened to get rid of
some of this stuff we don't need
that's very weird
it just seems like there's no
hmm all right let me let me paste this
here so I don't lose it and then let's
try to go here
well I kind of think we should just do a
new build let me double check in the App
Store
see this one unresolved issue
I just wonder all right if anybody who's
done anything like this before with
x-bow let me know what I'm not sure
about is would like how does this update
get yet up hit to here right is it is it
somehow pulling in the updated
JavaScript I'm very I'm really not sure
it's gonna show up load so it's on app
load
interesting well you know what I guess I
could test this I could probably test
this on my phone because I have the stay
focused app the Android version so if I
can type in test
all right so definitely does not work on
my Android version so I'm guessing that
the update did not work oh yeah it did I
just had to refresh the app so
I guess it worked that's insane I can't
believe that Wow
okay cool so I just went to my Android
app and I have so this has already been
released to Android right the demo mode
was not released Android right we just
coded it right here we did the update I
didn't have to resubmit anything but all
I did was a win in I like manually shut
down the app right in Android and then
opened it back up it really it evidently
loaded the new JavaScript it took like
less than a second I typed in tests and
it the demo mode worked so I think I
don't need to do anything here I think
like I've updated the app information so
let's double check to make sure that's
still in there yep cool so that's there
so I think this shouldn't work and we'll
submit that and then it says respond
others and everyone wears on the page I
guess I don't need let me just yeah well
I'll just click that off of there and
then that way sure that you select the
correct answer for advertising and you
just like know the binary will be
permanently rejected you know submit to
different by different let's see I
believe I need to use this right and we
did this
well we did this on our last livestream
how where when did we do this I'm just
gonna go to the other livestream this is
gonna be like the most meta thing that
I've ever done all right so let's go to
number part 6 and let's figure out where
we entered that stuff in all right so
here's we're entering in data
[Music]
I'll make this bigger just so that I can
read what it is all right back
is is still where is this
alright this is still building
everything trying to look through the
bottom here to see
see what we're typing in I remember what
this screen looks like all right so I'm
looking for a screen that looks like
this with checkboxes
let's do playback speed double and then
I also look for checkboxes on the screen
I thought this would be faster than
going back through the Expo
documentation to find where it talks
about this but it's possible that this
will not be faster
that's where I'm chatting so skip that I
think the end of the video is oh wait is
this it I think this might be it might
be around here
your release is gonna tell me where I
get the answers
this is the same thing I was looking for
in the last ream kind of find the answer
to
I can't find exactly where it is shoot
all right I'm gonna have to go through
the Expo documentation let's see if I
can search for this maybe a Google
search your help yes I
all right google search to the rescue
I'm gonna throw this on my other screen
real quick and then so we could fill
this out again so I don't want to mess
this up because this is like legal stuff
and we'll definitely could determine
whether or not my app gets accepted or
not so that's why I took so long to find
it this is a necessary thing
all right so attribute tribute to SAP
installation to a previously served over
time check the following boxes so need
to check yes should be it an action
taken of this up his fans all right
these three there we go
very cool and see if it'll let me change
the version cuz I cool
awesome awesome awesome waiting for
review and it did say said respond to
that yeah it did once you completed all
the changes reply to this message in the
resolution center we will continue the
review all right how do I reply mmm I do
not see a way to reply
anybody see a way to reply to this
well I don't know how to reply to that I
guess I can go to theirs there's nothing
on here that says resolution
center-right reply to this message in
resolution Center and we would continue
the review that's weird I guess I could
check I think they sent me an email
I'm gonna check my gmail on my other
screen and see if if I can reply to the
email
like it doesn't it doesn't say to reply
and when I go click to go to a
resolution senator just brings me right
back to here the only thing I can think
of I mean let me pull this back down to
a hundred percent maybe some part of the
UI is not here oops it doesn't look like
it though
I guess it's worth
we're searching how to reply message in
the resolution center area the heck is
this
enter a username why I'm already logged
in
guys
are you serious I just wanted to read
this thing
stackoverflow there we go
I don't think that exactly seeing it
yeah I guess I'm just gonna have to go
ahead and submit just check that I'll
use your name is okay
I submit waiting to be confirmed come on
that's really crazy that I can't I can't
actually see my stuff
yes all right finally that's pretty wild
you can't even see the developer forums
no I did not mean to click on that
you can respond to active resolution
Center issues for us by tapping on the
alert banner within iTunes Connect for
iOS hmm this has if you make any changes
you lose the ability to reply
hmm
okay so it seems like the iTunes Connect
iOS app has a reply button which I don't
have an iOS device right now so that's
not gonna work
all right interesting so there's no
reply button although I'm not I guess it
will be fine because like it says I mean
it says waiting for review now they
should be notified that something was
updated so I'm gonna say I'll just wait
and see
I'll wait a couple days to see if they
say anything if not I can go through
support I guess but for now I'm gonna
try to answer as many questions as I can
gotta get help get the kids ready for
bed here in a few minutes so I can't
answer a ton of questions but I'll see
what I can do anyway I mean we basically
succeeded in doing what we you know set
out to do for this dream so I'm happy
about that we should find out in a few
days whether or not this you know gets
successfully added to the App Store just
pretty sweet I know there are some
people that use they use the they use
iOS devices so they couldn't test the
app so now they will be able to and then
maybe on the next stream hopefully if
this gets submitted the next dream we
can do the web app version and then
anybody can try it out as long as they
can get on a browser and if they have
one of the headsets all right
you ukelele Daka says what does TSX mean
it's type scripts particularly its type
scripts with relay reacts JSX syntax
that's that syntax that kind of looks
like HTML but it's really not so this
kind of stuff here let me show you
so like this kind of stuff here well you
have like the angle brackets that looks
kind of like HTML that's called JSX so
if you want to use typescript with JSX
you give it the dot tsx extension
hum-hum Zita asked what's typescript
typescript is what you would call it a
superset of JavaScript so it's adds
additional features into JavaScript
mostly what it adds are types to
JavaScript so a JavaScript if you want
to know more about that actually did a
video on my youtube channel about that
so there's a link in my description in
the description to my youtube channel I
did a video not that long ago it's like
an intro to type script so check out
that video I go in-depth a lot more into
what typescript is but the short answer
is it adds types to JavaScript social
network snappa Graham says we love free
code camp five stars
thank you appreciate it
a couple of people were asking what this
was and then some of you in the chat
actually kind of explained it in a chat
so I'm gonna skip over that for now
thank you so much for providing this
those explanations for those either did
sherry says hey love from Brazil awesome
thanks for for joining us I wonder what
my sure what time zones are in Brazil if
I Brazil is pretty big so I'm assuming
there's different time zones cherry if
you're still on there what time is it in
Brazil right now I think how that would
line up if the eastern part of Brazil
would be the same time zone as me I
don't know
Johnny says hi from Colombia take care
hey how's it going Mike Micah Micah I
believe is how you pronounce sets is
says in Helsinki Finland restaurants are
closed schools are closed says I only go
to shop in the night time the economy is
going down that's about it so earlier in
the stream I had asked someone had asked
me how the quarantine is going and I had
kind of said what was going on here and
I'd asked what was going on and the rest
of the world so that's why Mike I
responded with that but yeah the economy
is that's kind of worrying that it seems
like like I mention early a lot of
people have lost their jobs already in
the United States and I'm assuming it's
a similar around the world that's that's
gonna be tough I know like here the
government's trying to just basically
give people money to make sure they
could still pay their bills and stuff
but that's also gonna cause problems as
well I'm sure there's gonna be inflation
down the road because of that so it's
hard to predict you know exactly what's
gonna happen from all that but I'm sure
it's it's probably gonna be it's gonna
be a while before things you know get
back to being stable in terms of like
people having jobs and everything
see there's a cool discussion about
different ways you can create apps
specifically between like Android using
like native Android or react native so
check that out if you're if you're
watching this at this time like and
you're interested in that maybe check
out that chat in the live chat I'm not
gonna read it out cuz the chat gets
saved so y'all can check it out but
there's some good stuff in there
Loran says in hungry food stores are
open
elders are allowed out between 9 and 12
to shop only hotels restaurants and
parks are closed a lot of IT jobs are
available programmers senior programmers
around $3,000 net what's good to do is
jobs still available I'd have noticed
some of the stores around here have
certain hours where older people can go
since they're more susceptible to
getting the virus so that's good
cybertek security says you have good
skill for programming thank you I
appreciate it
I would hope by now but I'm like
starting to get a little bit better at
programming I've been doing it for a
long time so I can definitely make
things work at this point
Moustafa ask what platform I'm using
this is react native it's a JavaScript
library and also so Darin actually
answered that question thanks Darren I
didn't see that until now but he says
also said coding on vs code Windows 10
and deploying to iOS that's awesome
that's a better answer than I gave to
okay Wow it's in hungry it's too after
2:00 a.m. at this point thanks for
staying up and watching randy says hello
from Monrovia Liberia hey how's it going
thanks for joining us buzz says I'm in
India in the time is 541 a.m. what's the
time they're here I'm in the United
States in the eastern part of the United
States and it is 8:15 p.m. so I should
get what is that in like I know a lot of
the rest of the world uses like the
24-hour great time thing so what would
that be - I'd be 10 20 should be like
what 2016 right now yeah no not 2016 I
always get confused yeah yeah would be
28 because 8 p.m. is 20 right yeah I was
in Germany well I guess it's been like
two years ago
and everything was in that time I
started to get good at doing that but in
the United States most people just use
the AM and PM Rajeev says hello I love
your channel watching from Mozambique I
love this channel a lot very nice coding
series keep coding oh thank you so much
I really appreciate that
so so beer John says hello from Luz
Becca Stan how long does it take to
learn JavaScript and what do you advise
for learning it thanks beforehand it's
really hard to tell how long it will
take because it depends a lot on your
situation but I would definitely
recommend going to free code camp org
and checking out the JavaScript lessons
there that's a great place to start
after that maybe check out some YouTube
videos
or you know some try to like maybe do
some of your own projects and look at
some documentation for JavaScript and
different JavaScript libraries but to
learn the basics and get started free
code campus one of the best places you
can go to Benedict says hello from
Malaysia it's 8 a.m. here it's so crazy
that all that the times are just so
different you know for some of you
you're just waking up some of you it's
the middle of the night for me I'm about
to get ready for bed
5:46 in India 2015 in yeah okay no p.m.
they're just 20 yeah
that's what I thought with the and that
was Randy said that Randy was I believe
in Monrovia yeah in Liberia oh no no I'm
sorry randy was just explaining to me
what time it would be like yet 2015 is
my time
okay man who says in France it's 1216 am
Laurentiis thanks for sharing your
knowledge take care next time try to do
live a little earlier I will I normally
don't do it this late but the kids
wanted to watch a movie and stuff we
actually we made homemade pasta and it
took like a really long time at all the
kids were helping and it took longer
than I thought
and then when they wanted to watch a
movie after Sunday usually we have we
all watch a movie together in the
afternoon
so anyway I'd anticipate him doing the
live stream a little earlier but better
to get it in even if it's late I suppose
alright so I'm gonna have to finish up
here and help get the kids ready for bed
my boys always like me to read Lord of
the Rings to them a little bit before
before bedtime so I want to make sure I
get up there and enough time to read to
them but maybe there's only a few more
questions so I'll read out a few more
and then we'll we'll finish ah
Achmed says hi I'm just starting to
learn to type but I'm determined to code
thank you
Oh awesome well good luck and I'm glad
you're determined I wish you lots of
success in learning how to typing code
Naveen has prerequisites for react
native definitely learned some Java
scripts before you try to jump right
into react native and so wad says in
Bangladesh it's 6:18 a.m. Moses says in
10 Tanzania it is 913 or I'm sorry 319
a.m. and all right one more message here
Brandi says just followed you on Twitter
is your workplace actually called Dick's
it is it's Dick's Sporting Goods the
founder of Dick's Sporting Goods is his
name was dick dick stacked so um anyway
that's why it is so I
usually say DSG or Dick's Sporting Goods
I'm just I'm sure you can understand why
I would normally say it like that but
yeah that's where I work right now at
Dick's Sporting Goods and they're only
in the United States but they're they're
the biggest sporting goods store in the
United States we have over 700 locations
all over the country but yeah anyway
that's all for me for this livestream
thank you all so much for for watching
and stick it in there you know when all
right we had a little bit of trouble
there at the end just trying to figure
out what to what to put there in the App
Store but I want to try to get another
stream in here hopefully it's not too
long before my next stream I'm gonna try
to do at least one stream a week if I
can hopefully more but also if you're
interested in the stuff that I'm doing I
have put up some tutorial videos on my
channel about react native and
typescript and stuff like that
so click the link in the description of
the video to check out my youtube
channel if you're interested and yeah
also let me know if there's anything you
want to learn more about I don't really
have a ton of time when I do the live
stream to really like explain everything
thoroughly
because we're trying to do real code but
I'm more than happy to do it like a
video explaining things so just send me
a message in the in the comments or on
Twitter or something like that and I
usually get back to everybody pretty
quickly and yeah so until next time you
know have a great beginning of the week
and stay safe and I'll see you later